Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky BBQ glaze and topped with a creamy BBQ sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Sunday March 1, 1998, crime scene examiners gathered at a residence on Main Avenue in the upscale Queensland suburb of Wilston. The two-story, cream-coloured weatherboard home sat on a sloped hill that overlooked Brisbane's CBD, which was five kilometres away. It was far from a remote location, yet the property's position against the old and hill reservoir granted it a bushland backdrop akin to a rural homestead. The house itself was barely visible from the street, practically hidden amongst the thicket of trees and shrubbery that defined the front garden. A path wove between the forest-like surrounds to a set of timber stairs that led to the front door of the upper level. Inside the house, boxes and paperwork were strewn across the carpet, which was also covered with old newspapers, cat cages and upended furniture. An antique Beckstein piano took pride of place in the lounge room. A music book was open on its stand.
你试过在烧烤上再加烧烤吗？想象一下：新鲜烹制的酥脆调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉，再淋上一层奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来？那你现在就可以去蒂姆餐厅尝尝。限时供应我们全新的烧烤脆皮鸡肉碗和卷饼。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。1998年3月1日星期日，犯罪现场调查员聚集在昆士兰州威尔斯顿高档郊区主大道的一处住宅。这座两层楼高的奶油色木板房坐落在一个斜坡上，俯瞰着五公里外的布里斯班中央商务区。这里远非偏远地区，但该房产背靠艾尔山水库的位置，使其拥有了类似于乡村宅邸的丛林背景。从街上几乎看不见房子，它实际上隐藏在定义了前花园的茂密树木和灌木丛中。一条小路在森林般的环绕中蜿蜒而行，通向通往上层前门的一组木楼梯。屋内，纸箱和文件散落在地毯上，地毯上还铺满了旧报纸、猫笼和翻倒的家具。一架古董贝希斯坦钢琴在客厅里占据了显眼的位置。琴架上摊开着一本乐谱。
When a detective saw which composition the page was turned to, a chill ran through him. Was it a message? The famous piece by Polish pianist Frédéric Chopin was titled The Funeral March. The Funeral March 52-year-old doctor Kathleen Marshall was a well-respected veterinarian in Wilston, renowned for her devotion to animal welfare. She worked out of her main avenue home, having converted the lower level of her two-story house into a small clinic that was completely independent from the living space on top. Situated between two single-car garages, she used the space to do the occasional vaccination or health check for friends and acquaintances, but it mainly served as a centre for her to care for her own pets. While Kathleen loved all animals, she had a particular affinity for cats. She owned 16 of them, earning her the reputation of Wilston's catwoman. With three dogs as well, her home was in a constant state of disarray, but she was comfortable there.
当一名侦探看到乐谱翻开的那一页时，不禁感到一阵寒意。这是一种暗示吗？这首由波兰钢琴家弗雷德里克·肖邦创作的著名乐曲名为《葬礼进行曲》。《葬礼进行曲》。52岁的凯瑟琳·马歇尔医生是威尔斯顿一位受人尊敬的兽医，以致力于动物福利而闻名。她在主大道的家中工作，将两层楼房的底层改造成了一个小型诊所，与楼上的生活空间完全独立。她利用位于两个单车库之间的空间，偶尔为朋友和熟人提供疫苗接种或健康检查，但这里主要作为她照顾自己宠物的中心。虽然凯瑟琳热爱所有动物，但她对猫情有独钟。她养了16只猫，这让她赢得了“威尔斯顿猫女”的称号。再加上三只狗，她的家总是处于混乱状态，但她在那里感到很自在。
Kathleen's front garden was in a similar state. Equally passionate about the environment, Kathleen had turned the space into a small, overgrown forest. Yet the abundance of foliage couldn't obscure everything that went on behind it. By Friday, February 27, 1998, witnesses had noticed a light emanating from Kathleen's veterinary clinic that never turned off. That night, Kathleen had organised a dinner in the city for 7 o'clock. As a means of expanding her social circle, she had founded a group named a Lepicure for professional singles aged 35 and over. Twice monthly, members would meet at an upmarket restaurant in Brisbane for a night of fine dining and conversation. Kathleen orchestrated the group's events meticulously and agonised over every detail, with attendees having to RSVP and pay for the meal in advance. Therefore, members were left confused when Kathleen's seat at the table that night remained empty.
凯瑟琳的前花园也处于类似的状态。凯瑟琳同样热爱环境，她把这个空间变成了一个杂草丛生的小森林。然而，茂密的枝叶并不能掩盖背后发生的一切。到1998年2月27日星期五，目击者注意到凯瑟琳的兽医诊所里有一盏灯从未熄灭。那天晚上，凯瑟琳在城里组织了一场7点的晚餐。为了扩大社交圈，她创办了一个名为“Lepicure”的组织，面向35岁及以上的单身专业人士。每月两次，成员们会在布里斯班的一家高档餐厅聚会，享受美食和交谈。凯瑟琳精心策划了该团体的活动，并对每一个细节都绞尽脑汁，参加者必须提前回复并支付餐费。因此，当那天晚上凯瑟琳在餐桌上的座位空着时，成员们感到非常困惑。
They dialed Kathleen's phone to see where she was, but their calls went straight to the answering machine. This wasn't unusual for Kathleen, but her unexplained absence certainly was. No one saw Kathleen over the weekend. Then, just after 3pm on Sunday, three members of the Cat Protection Society of Queensland arrived at Kathleen's home. The organisation was one of the many charitable ventures that occupied Kathleen's spare time. As one of its directors, Kathleen had been expected to attend an important meeting earlier that day, but she never showed. A second, smaller meeting between directors was then scheduled to take place afterwards at Kathleen's house, which served as the society's headquarters. As the other Cat Protection Society members exited their car and made their way towards Kathleen's house that afternoon, they were immediately struck by a foul stench.
他们拨打了凯瑟琳的电话想看看她在哪里，但电话直接转到了语音信箱。这对凯瑟琳来说并不罕见，但她无法解释的缺席确实很反常。整个周末没有人见到凯瑟琳。然后，在周日下午3点刚过，昆士兰猫保护协会的三名成员来到了凯瑟琳家。该组织是凯瑟琳业余时间从事的众多慈善事业之一。作为董事之一，凯瑟琳本应在那天早些时候参加一次重要会议，但她从未露面。随后，董事们在凯瑟琳家安排了第二次小型会议，这里也是该协会的总部。当其他猫保护协会成员那天下午下车走向凯瑟琳家时，他们立刻闻到了一股恶臭。
Several outside bins were overflowing with rubbish, which they assumed was to blame for the odour. The trio made their way up the driveway, noticing that several deliveries, including three newspapers and two cartons of milk, had been ignored. They ascended the stairs to the front door. An envelope was stuck against it with brown packing tape. Leaving it be, they knocked and called out for Kathleen, but there was no response. Kathleen suffered from a medical condition known as Cushing disease, which often caused her to feel tired and unwell. Her friends worried that she might have fallen severely ill or had some other health emergency and was unable to answer them. One of the women rushed to the rear of their house where they knew Kathleen kept a spare key.
外面的几个垃圾桶里塞满了垃圾，他们认为这就是臭味的来源。三人沿着车道走去，注意到几份快递，包括三份报纸和两盒牛奶，都没有人理会。他们走上楼梯来到前门。一个信封用棕色包装胶带粘在门上。他们没有动它，而是敲门并呼喊凯瑟琳，但没有任何回应。凯瑟琳患有一种被称为库欣氏病的疾病，这常使她感到疲倦和不适。她的朋友们担心她可能病得很重，或者发生了其他健康紧急情况，无法回应他们。其中一名妇女冲向他们知道凯瑟琳存放备用钥匙的房子后部。
As she approached, the foul smell wafting around her intensified and flies started buzzing around her head. She moved past the frosted glass door that led into Kathleen's vet clinic and paused. Blood was smeared on the glass. Alarmed, the woman called out to the others and they gathered around the door. It wouldn't open. Beyond the obscured glass, they could make out something on the floor inside. It was an outstretched arm. The police were called and officers arrived within minutes.
当她走近时，周围弥漫的恶臭加剧了，苍蝇开始在她头顶嗡嗡作响。她经过通往凯瑟琳兽医诊所的磨砂玻璃门，停了下来。玻璃上沾着血迹。惊慌失措的她呼唤其他人，他们聚集在门边。门打不开。透过模糊的玻璃，他们可以看到里面的地板上有东西。那是一只伸出的手臂。警察被叫来了，警官们在几分钟内就赶到了。
It appeared as though a struggle had taken place right outside Kathleen's clinic. Blood was splattered onto some foliage near the door and the rubber door mat was also heavily bloodstained. But there were no bloody shoe prints leading to or from the area. More police were summoned to the house and just as they were about to begin a thorough examination of the property's exterior, an automatic sprinkler activated, washing away possible evidence from the driveway and surrounds. The clinic below Kathleen's home had two access points, the frosted glass door which acted as its entry and a sliding glass door at its rear. There was no internal access point from the upstairs residence and the frosted glass door was sealed shut. As an officer circled the property, they came across a small window in the garage that looked into the clinic.
看起来在凯瑟琳诊所外发生了一场搏斗。门附近的树叶上溅有血迹，橡胶门垫上也沾满了血迹。但该区域周围没有通往或离开的血脚印。更多的警察被召集到房子里，就在他们准备开始对房产外部进行彻底检查时，一个自动喷水装置启动了，冲走了车道和周围可能存在的证据。凯瑟琳家下方的诊所有两个入口，一个是作为入口的磨砂玻璃门，另一个是后部的滑动玻璃门。楼上的住宅没有内部入口，磨砂玻璃门被封死了。当一名警官绕着房产巡视时，他们发现车库里有一扇小窗户可以看到诊所内部。
It featured a series of horizontal glass slats that could be opened and shut in unison to control airflow. Some of the slats had been snapped off as though someone had broken in. But the pieces lay at the officer's feet, meaning someone had actually broken out. Looking through the window, the officer saw Kathleen Marshall lying face down in a pool of blood. She was positioned beside the consultation table in the middle of the room with her head turned to one side and her hands clutching at her shoulder length brown hair. Her blue and white striped sundress was gathered around her chest, exposing a stab wound that pierced the back of her bloody debra. Officers soon realised that the clinic door was actually unlocked but a heavy cat cage had been pushed up against it. A crime scene examiner managed to force his way in and found so much blood that stepping equipment had to be placed on the floor to prevent investigators from contaminating the area.
它有一系列可以同时打开和关闭的水平玻璃板来控制气流。一些板条被折断了，好像有人闯入一样。但碎片掉在警官脚下，这意味着有人实际上是从里面破窗而出。透过窗户，警官看到凯瑟琳·马歇尔脸朝下躺在血泊中。她位于房间中央的诊疗台旁边，头转向一边，双手紧紧抓着她齐肩长的棕色头发。她那件蓝白条纹的夏装被卷到胸前，露出了刺穿她血淋淋背部的刀伤。警官们很快意识到诊所的门其实没锁，但一个沉重的猫笼被推到了门后。一名犯罪现场调查员设法强行进入，发现血迹太多，必须在地板上放置垫脚设备，以防止调查人员污染现场。
It appeared the altercation that had started outside the clinic had continued indoors, with defence wounds indicating that Kathleen had put up a fight. A white bucket underneath the sink contained bloody water, a dishcloth, Kathleen's glasses and one running shoe. The matching shoe sat next to the bucket. There were also droplets of watered down blood on a plastic bag next to the sink. It looked as though the killer had tried to clean themselves and the crime scene before fleeing. A collapsed cardboard box was propped against the wall beneath the broken window depicting their exit route. It too had blood on it, leading investigators to wonder if the killer had injured themselves during the attack. A total of 26 swabs were taken throughout the space in the hope that they had left their DNA at the scene.
看起来在诊所外开始的争执一直持续到了室内，防御性伤口表明凯瑟琳进行了反抗。水槽下的一个白色水桶里装有血水、一块抹布、凯瑟琳的眼镜和一只跑鞋。另一只配套的鞋子放在水桶旁边。水槽旁的一个塑料袋上也有稀释的血滴。看起来凶手在逃跑前试图清理自己和犯罪现场。破碎窗户下方的墙边靠着一个压扁的纸板箱，描绘了他们的逃跑路线。上面也有血迹，这让调查人员怀疑凶手在袭击过程中是否受了伤。整个空间总共采集了26个拭子，希望他们能在现场留下DNA。
Kathleen had been stabbed with a sharp-tipped knife 52 times throughout her upper body. Her abdomen, chest and head had all been struck, with her face brutalised in such a manner that left her features unrecognisable. Yet, the wounds themselves were shallow, with the deepest measuring roughly four centimetres. Investigators speculated that Kathleen's attacker had either been a woman or a physically weaker man. In fact, only one wound was farmed to have been fatal. The severing of Kathleen's carotid artery in her neck resulted in her bleeding to death. Had she received intervention prior to losing consciousness, she might have survived. Kathleen didn't keep any opioids on site, and none of the prescription medications or other veterinary supplies had been touched,
凯瑟琳的上半身被一把尖刀刺了52次。她的腹部、胸部和头部都受到了重创，脸部被摧毁得面目全非。然而，伤口本身很浅，最深处大约只有四厘米。调查人员推测，凯瑟琳的袭击者要么是一名女性，要么是一名体力较弱的男性。事实上，只有一处伤口被认为是致命的。凯瑟琳颈部颈动脉的切断导致她失血过多而死。如果她在失去知觉前得到干预，她本可能幸存下来。凯瑟琳现场没有存放任何阿片类药物，也没有任何处方药或其他兽医用品被触碰，
ruling out the possibility that the murder was motivated by theft. The focus turned to Kathleen's upper-level residence, which was in such disarray that police initially thought it had been ransacked and was part of the crime scene. Kathleen's friends clarified that this was just how her house always looked. There were no signs of forced entry into that area of the home, and nothing had been stolen. Amongst the clutter on Kathleen's dining table was her daily planner. The last entry was made on Thursday, February 26. 1998, three days before her body was discovered. Kathleen had jotted down a 12.30pm veterinary appointment for client Matthew Thompson and his dog, Jazz.
排除了谋杀是出于盗窃动机的可能性。调查重点转向了凯瑟琳楼上的住所，那里乱七八糟，警察最初认为它被洗劫过，是犯罪现场的一部分。凯瑟琳的朋友澄清说，她的房子一直都是这个样子。该区域没有强行闯入的迹象，也没有任何东西被盗。在凯瑟琳餐桌上的杂物中，有她的日常计划表。最后一条记录是在1998年2月26日星期四，即她被发现尸体的前三天。凯瑟琳记下了一个下午12点30分的兽医预约，客户是马修·汤普森和他的狗“爵士”。
Investigators spoke to Matthew, who noted nothing out of the ordinary with Kathleen that day. It appeared as though she was a victim of theft. It appeared as though she was attacked soon thereafter, with the decomposition progression of her remains showing that she had lain undiscovered in her clinic for days. Professor Russell Luke, the head of the Parasitology Reference Laboratory at Queensland Health Scientific Services, examined maggots that had infested Kathleen's wounds. Based on the state of their development, he estimated Kathleen was killed sometime between 9pm on Thursday and 3am on Friday. Several of Kathleen's beloved cats were locked in cages within the clinic, unable to access food or water over the weekend. One suffered kidney disease as a direct result and subsequently had to be euthanized. The others were unfed and distressed upstairs.
调查人员与马修谈过，他指出那天凯瑟琳没有什么异常。看起来她很快就遭到了袭击，她遗体的腐烂程度表明她在诊所里躺了几天才被发现。昆士兰卫生科学服务部寄生虫学参考实验室主任拉塞尔·卢克教授检查了凯瑟琳伤口上的蛆虫。根据它们的发育状态，他估计凯瑟琳是在周四晚上9点到周五凌晨3点之间的某个时间被杀的。凯瑟琳心爱的几只猫被锁在诊所的笼子里，整个周末都无法获得食物或水。其中一只因此直接患上了肾病，随后不得不被安乐死。其他的猫在楼上没有进食，处于痛苦之中。
Kathleen's dogs were found secured outside on her balcony, which led some to believe Kathleen had placed them there prior to her murder in preparation for company. This theory suited the nature of the crime itself. Knife-based attacks are considered intimate and personal violence, and the fact that Kathleen was targeted in her own home meant the killer knew she lived there alone. 52 stab wounds was a particularly frenzied overkill, hinting at a perpetrator who harboured deep hatred for Kathleen. Who that person could be wasn't easy to answer, as it was no secret that Kathleen had rubbed many people the wrong way. Described as having a dominant personality, Kathleen also had incredibly high standards and wasn't afraid to speak her mind. Some members of LEPIQA were unhappy with her selective membership criteria, which required male participants to have a university degree and female members to have two. Kathleen had also drawn the ire of a neighbour who'd petitioned the Brisbane City Council to cut back overgrown trees in Kathleen's front yard that were restricting access to the footpath.
凯瑟琳的狗被发现关在阳台外面，这让一些人认为凯瑟琳在谋杀前为了迎接客人把它们放在了那里。这个理论符合犯罪本身的性质。刀具袭击被认为是亲密和个人暴力，而凯瑟琳在自己家中成为目标意味着凶手知道她独自居住。52处刀伤是一种特别疯狂的过度杀戮，暗示凶手对凯瑟琳怀有深仇大恨。那个人是谁并不容易回答，因为凯瑟琳得罪了很多人并不是什么秘密。凯瑟琳被描述为具有支配型人格，标准极高，而且敢于直言不讳。一些LEPIQA成员对她选择性的会员标准感到不满，该标准要求男性参与者拥有大学学位，女性成员拥有两个。凯瑟琳还引起了一位邻居的愤怒，该邻居曾向布里斯班市议会请愿，要求砍掉凯瑟琳前院里限制通往人行道通道的杂草丛生的树木。
Fiercely protective of the environment, Kathleen had to be forcibly restrained by police so that workers could cut down the offending foliage. Kathleen had also fallen out with her family after being the sole beneficiary to her father's will after his death 20 years prior. Her siblings had tried to mend the rift, but Kathleen had refused every family gathering invite and had never met any of her nieces and nephews. And her marriage had ended in divorce seven years earlier. Yet there was nothing to suggest that any of these people were out to kill her. While forthright and straightforward, at her core Kathleen was a selfless and generous person. Her murder came as a shock to all who knew her. As night fell on the crime scene, members of the Cat Protection Society gathered in Kathleen's front yard to console one another.
凯瑟琳极力保护环境，不得不被警察强行制止，以便工人们砍掉那些碍事的树叶。凯瑟琳在20年前父亲去世后成为遗嘱的唯一受益人，也与家人闹翻了。她的兄弟姐妹曾试图弥合裂痕，但凯瑟琳拒绝了每一次家庭聚会的邀请，也从未见过她的任何侄子侄女。她的婚姻也在七年前以离婚告终。然而，没有任何迹象表明这些人中有谁想杀她。虽然直率坦诚，但凯瑟琳本质上是一个无私慷慨的人。她的谋杀案让所有认识她的人感到震惊。当夜幕降临犯罪现场时，猫保护协会的成员聚集在凯瑟琳的前院互相安慰。
As they spoke amongst themselves, one officer heard a loud gasp. They approached the group and asked what was wrong. Glenda Whitmore, one of the three women who discovered the crime scene, told the officer, Kathleen's murderer has just driven past. Virginia Houston and Kathleen Marshall met towards the end of 1996. Both women lived in homes that bordered the Isle and Hill Reserve and had petitioned to preserve the natural space. Like Kathleen, 45 year old Virginia was not one to shy away from causes she believed in, and it was little surprise that the pair initially hit it off. When Virginia found out that Kathleen was a veterinarian who loved cats, she invited her to join the Cat Protection Society of Queensland.
当他们交谈时，一名警官听到了一声大喘气。他们走近人群，询问发生了什么事。发现犯罪现场的三名妇女之一格伦达·惠特莫尔告诉警官：“凯瑟琳的凶手刚刚开车经过。”弗吉尼亚·休斯顿和凯瑟琳·马歇尔在1996年底相识。两位女性居住的房屋都与艾尔山保护区接壤，并曾请愿保护这一自然空间。和凯瑟琳一样，45岁的弗吉尼亚也不是一个会回避她所信仰事业的人，两人一拍即合也就不足为奇了。当弗吉尼亚发现凯瑟琳是一位爱猫的兽医时，她邀请她加入昆士兰猫保护协会。
Virginia was one of the directors and also the treasurer. The society had been slowly degrading due to members fighting and accusations of money going missing, and Virginia saw Kathleen as a valuable ally who could help investigate the alleged corruption that was plaguing them. Kathleen accepted Virginia's offer, but their relationship soon soured. Kathleen lost sight of the reason why she was brought into the fold and focused her attention on advocacy instead of mediation. She used her position to implement changes that would benefit the local stray and injured cat population as opposed to settling the group's inner conflicts and financial issues. Virginia was disappointed, and by mid-1997 the society had splintered into two factions, those who supported Kathleen and those who supported Virginia. Kathleen's supporters were appreciative of her efforts to steer the ship back to promoting feline welfare, while her critics viewed her as rude, abrupt, insulting and demeaning.
弗吉尼亚是董事之一，也是财务主管。由于成员间的争斗和资金失踪的指控，该协会一直在缓慢衰落，弗吉尼亚将凯瑟琳视为可以帮助调查困扰他们的所谓腐败的宝贵盟友。凯瑟琳接受了弗吉尼亚的邀请，但他们的关系很快恶化。凯瑟琳忘记了她被拉入伙的原因，将注意力集中在倡导上，而不是调解上。她利用自己的职位实施了有利于当地流浪猫和受伤猫群的变革，而不是解决该团体的内部冲突和财务问题。弗吉尼亚感到失望，到1997年中期，该协会分裂为两个派系：支持凯瑟琳的人和支持弗吉尼亚的人。凯瑟琳的支持者赞赏她将协会重新引向促进猫科动物福利的努力，而她的批评者则认为她粗鲁、唐突、侮辱人和贬低人。
Kathleen and Virginia fought constantly and made no effort to hide their dislike of one another. Then, in August 1997, Virginia was ousted as director and treasurer at a vote of 42-2. Kathleen, on the other hand, rose to the role of director. Virginia was devastated by her demotion and set about reporting the society to the Australian Securities and Investment Commission on allegations of vote rigging. Meanwhile, tensions within the group heightened. Weeks before Kathleen's murder, Virginia arrived at her doorstep wanting her to review some paperwork, but Kathleen refused to let her in. The two got into a scuffle, pushing, shoving and pulling each other's hair. Kathleen called the police to report that she, quote, had a mad woman in her house.
凯瑟琳和弗吉尼亚不断争吵，毫不掩饰对彼此的厌恶。然后，在1997年8月，弗吉尼亚在一次42比2的投票中被免去董事和财务主管的职务。另一方面，凯瑟琳升任董事。弗吉尼亚对她的降职感到崩溃，并开始向澳大利亚证券和投资委员会举报该协会，指控其操纵投票。与此同时，团体内部的紧张局势加剧。在凯瑟琳被谋杀前几周，弗吉尼亚来到她家门口想让她审查一些文件，但凯瑟琳拒绝让她进去。两人发生了争执，推搡、拉扯对方的头发。凯瑟琳报警称她“家里有个疯女人”。
She claimed to have hurt her hand in the altercation, but declined to press charges against Virginia. Afterwards, Kathleen began looking over her shoulder and told a fellow society director that she was certain she was being stalked. One day, she had smelled cigarette smoke while out on her back veranda and suspected a smoker had been trespassing at the rear of her property. Kathleen told others that she was scared of Virginia Houston and had even expressed her belief that Virginia was capable of taking a knife to her. In the words of Kathleen, they had to, quote, get the bitch. On the day Kathleen's body was discovered, an envelope was found stuck to her front door with brown packing tape. It was from Virginia Houston and contained information for the Cat Protection Society meeting that was due to be held that day. Held at a local school hall, it was pitched as a talk fest, wherein members could address and resolve issues impacting the group.
她声称在争执中伤了手，但拒绝起诉弗吉尼亚。此后，凯瑟琳开始变得疑神疑鬼，并告诉一位协会董事，她确信自己被跟踪了。有一天，她在后阳台上闻到了烟味，怀疑有人在她的房产后部非法闯入。凯瑟琳告诉别人她害怕弗吉尼亚·休斯顿，甚至表示她相信弗吉尼亚有能力拿刀刺她。用凯瑟琳的话说，他们必须“干掉那个婊子”。在凯瑟琳尸体被发现的那天，一个用棕色包装胶带粘在前门上的信封被发现。它来自弗吉尼亚·休斯顿，包含了当天预定举行的猫保护协会会议的信息。会议在当地一所学校礼堂举行，被宣传为一场讨论会，成员们可以在会上提出并解决影响该团体的问题。
As a director, Kathleen was expected to attend, and her conflict with Virginia would no doubt have been discussed. Despite being one half of one of the group's major conflicts, Virginia Houston had no desire to attend the talk fest. Given her demotion, she was also not invited to the director's meeting planned immediately afterwards at Kathleen's house. Yet, that night, Virginia was spotted driving by the crime scene. When speaking with police, Virginia Houston was frank about her dislike of Kathleen, but maintained she would never kill her. In fact, she intended to sue Kathleen for defamation, so according to Virginia, Kathleen's untimely death had lost her a lot of money. While she denied stalking Kathleen, she openly admitted to often driving past her house to see if the Cat Protection Society was meeting. A fellow society member vouched for Virginia's whereabouts on the Thursday night it was estimated that Kathleen was killed.
作为董事，凯瑟琳本应出席，她与弗吉尼亚的冲突无疑会被讨论。尽管是该团体主要冲突的一方，弗吉尼亚·休斯顿却无意参加讨论会。鉴于她被降职，她也没有被邀请参加随后立即在凯瑟琳家举行的董事会议。然而，那天晚上，有人看到弗吉尼亚开车经过犯罪现场。在与警方交谈时，弗吉尼亚·休斯顿坦率地表达了她对凯瑟琳的厌恶，但坚称她永远不会杀她。事实上，她打算起诉凯瑟琳诽谤，所以据弗吉尼亚说，凯瑟琳的英年早逝让她损失了很多钱。虽然她否认跟踪凯瑟琳，但她公开承认经常开车经过她家，看看猫保护协会是否在开会。一位协会成员为弗吉尼亚在凯瑟琳被杀的周四晚上的行踪作了担保。
The pair were together from 5pm, organizing a mail-out for society members. Virginia left at 11pm and had no alibi for the remaining hours Kathleen could have been targeted. She said she visited Kathleen's residence with a friend at around 4.10pm on Friday to drop off the information pertaining to Sunday's meeting. She decided to tape the documents in an envelope to the front door because she knew Kathleen would never open the door to her. Later that night, Virginia had driven past to see if the envelope had been taken, but it was still there. She didn't drive by again until Sunday evening, expecting to see the meeting underway, but instead finding Kathleen's house cordoned off by police. Virginia Houston's confidence and honesty led detectives to believe that she had taken time to consider, rehearse and perfect her responses in anticipation of being questioned. Virginia maintained, quote,
两人从下午5点开始在一起，为协会成员整理邮件。弗吉尼亚在晚上11点离开，对于凯瑟琳可能被袭击的剩余时间没有不在场证明。她说她在周五下午4点10分左右和一位朋友一起去了凯瑟琳的住所，送交有关周日会议的信息。她决定把文件装在信封里贴在前门上，因为她知道凯瑟琳永远不会给她开门。那天晚上晚些时候，弗吉尼亚开车经过看看信封是否被拿走了，但它还在那里。直到周日晚上她才再次开车经过，本以为会看到会议正在进行，却发现凯瑟琳的房子被警察封锁了。弗吉尼亚·休斯顿的自信和诚实让侦探们认为，她在预料到会被审问时，花时间考虑、排练并完善了她的回答。弗吉尼亚坚持说：
Because of the type of person Kathleen was, she created a lot of enemies and it could have been anyone in any of the compartments of her life. A fierce supporter of Virginia's told the Courier Mail, The police have got it all wrong. Virginia didn't do it. Kathleen was a very strong woman. It would have taken a man. Police interviewed 70 other members of the Cat Protection Society, nearly all of whom were certain that Virginia Houston could have murdered Kathleen Marshall. Six days into their investigation, detectives arrived at Virginia's home with a search warrant. Her car was seized and her property thoroughly examined. 30 state emergency services volunteers also scoured the Isle and Hill Reservoir, as detectives believed Virginia could have crossed the bushland to gain access to Kathleen's property from behind. A suspicious stain in Virginia's home hinted at a possible breakthrough, but luminal testing determined it wasn't blood.
“因为凯瑟琳是那种人，她树敌很多，可能是她生活中的任何一个环节里的任何人。”弗吉尼亚的一位坚定支持者告诉《信使邮报》：“警察完全搞错了。弗吉尼亚没做。凯瑟琳是一个非常强壮的女人。这需要一个男人。”警方采访了猫保护协会的其他70名成员，几乎所有人都确信弗吉尼亚·休斯顿可能谋杀了凯瑟琳·马歇尔。调查进行到第六天，侦探们带着搜查令来到弗吉尼亚家。她的车被扣押，房产也经过了彻底检查。30名州紧急服务志愿者也搜查了艾尔山水库，因为侦探们认为弗吉尼亚可能穿过丛林从后面进入凯瑟琳的房产。弗吉尼亚家中一处可疑的污渍暗示了可能的突破，但鲁米诺测试确定那不是血迹。
Investigators were unable to uncover anything to link Virginia to the murder of Kathleen. The bizarre case had garnered significant media attention, with members of the press comparing it to an Agatha Christie murder mystery. Virginia Houston didn't shy away from the attention, often giving interviews from the front of her home, which she kept locked up with the curtains drawn. Virginia told reporters that she'd gone into hiding, believing Kathleen was targeted because of money. As the former treasurer for the Cat Protection Society, Virginia held concerns that she would be next. She said she knew too much about the group's financial affairs and feared for her life because of it. Her assertions weren't without merit. 16 years earlier in October 1982, a Cat Protection Society member named Frank Castagnola was shot and killed while sitting on his front porch.
调查人员无法发现任何将弗吉尼亚与凯瑟琳谋杀案联系起来的证据。这起离奇的案件引起了媒体的极大关注，新闻界成员将其比作阿加莎·克里斯蒂的谋杀悬疑小说。弗吉尼亚·休斯顿并没有回避这种关注，经常在她的家门口接受采访，她把家锁得紧紧的，窗帘拉得严严实实。弗吉尼亚告诉记者，她已经躲了起来，认为凯瑟琳是因为钱而成为目标的。作为猫保护协会的前财务主管，弗吉尼亚担心自己会是下一个。她说她知道太多关于该团体财务状况的事情，并因此担心自己的生命安全。她的断言并非没有根据。16年前的1982年10月，一位名叫弗兰克·卡斯塔尼奥拉的猫保护协会成员在坐在前廊时被枪杀。
He'd only joined the group earlier that year, and six months before his murder, he left the society his entire estate in the event of his death, which amounted to just over $200,000. In his forthcoming book, A History of the Queensland Cat Protection Society, A Story of Infighting, Money and Murder, author Ted Douze explained that Frank had been encouraged to leave his estate to the society by one of the group's acting chairpersons, Glenda Whitmore. Glenda was one of the three people that discovered Kathleen Marshall's body and had also identified Virginia Houston as Kathleen's killer. Secretary Barry Eastick had also persuaded Frank to hand over his money as he had realized the society's potential as a business rather than a charity. A coroner's inquest into Frank Castagnola's murder failed to identify the person or persons responsible. A case was made against Frank's neighbour who wasn't associated with the Cat Protection Society, but the murder remained unsolved. Still, a cloud of suspicion lingered over the society, although Kathleen Marshall hadn't left any of her own estate to the group.
他那年早些时候才加入该组织，在谋杀案发生前六个月，他将自己的全部遗产留给了协会，总额略高于20万美元。作者泰德·杜兹在他即将出版的《昆士兰猫保护协会史：内斗、金钱与谋杀的故事》一书中解释说，弗兰克是在该团体代理主席之一格伦达·惠特莫尔的鼓励下将遗产留给协会的。格伦达是发现凯瑟琳·马歇尔尸体的三人之一，也曾指认弗吉尼亚·休斯顿是凯瑟琳的凶手。秘书巴里·伊斯蒂克也曾说服弗兰克交出他的钱，因为他意识到该协会作为企业而不是慈善机构的潜力。对弗兰克·卡斯塔尼奥拉谋杀案的验尸官调查未能确定负责的人。有人对弗兰克的邻居提出了指控，该邻居与猫保护协会无关，但谋杀案仍未破获。尽管如此，一层怀疑的阴云仍笼罩着该协会，尽管凯瑟琳·马歇尔并没有将自己的遗产留给该团体。
It took over a month for the 26 swabs taken from Kathleen's clinic to be fully analyzed. DNA couldn't be extracted from 11 of them, and one of the samples had gone missing. Of the remaining 14, nine were found to contain Kathleen's DNA. Five swabs which were collected from bloodstaining on the cardboard box under the broken window, a wall, the floor and the plastic bag by the sink featured the DNA profile of a second individual, a male. This stunned investigators, completely shattering who they believed to be their main and only suspect. The discovery removed Virginia Houston from the scene, but didn't necessarily rule her out. Wondering if she had enlisted the help of a male accomplice, investigators zeroed in on the men in Virginia's life. Their efforts took them hundreds of kilometers into state, and by the end they had collected 42 DNA samples.
从凯瑟琳诊所采集的26个拭子花了超过一个月的时间才被完全分析。其中11个无法提取DNA，其中一个样本丢失了。在剩下的14个中，有9个被发现含有凯瑟琳的DNA。从破碎窗户下的纸板箱、墙壁、地板和水槽旁的塑料袋上的血迹中采集的5个拭子显示了第二个人的DNA图谱，是一名男性。这让调查人员感到震惊，彻底粉碎了他们认为的主要且唯一的嫌疑人。这一发现将弗吉尼亚·休斯顿从现场移除了，但并不一定排除了她的嫌疑。调查人员怀疑她是否寻求了男性同伙的帮助，于是将目光锁定在弗吉尼亚生活中的男性身上。他们的努力延伸到了州内数百公里外，最终收集了42个DNA样本。
They also collected samples from the men who Kathleen Marshall was known to. DNA testing in Australia was still in its infancy, and the large-scale testing effort was a lengthy and costly endeavor. But in the absence of any other leads, it seemed the most likely way to catch Kathleen's killer. The search led to the inner Brisbane suburb of Fortitude Valley, just a few kilometers from Wilston. Police had tracked down an ex-boyfriend of Virginia Houston's named Shane, not his real name, who resided at a boarding house there. Shane became combative when asked about Kathleen Marshall's murder, and he refused to provide a DNA sample. Given that he wasn't legally required to provide one, investigators surreptitiously followed Shane through the streets to see if an opportunity would present itself. When he spat on a footpath, the detectives seized their chance and swooped, obtaining a saliva sample for testing.
他们还收集了凯瑟琳·马歇尔所认识的男性的样本。澳大利亚的DNA测试仍处于起步阶段，大规模的测试工作是一项漫长且昂贵的努力。但在没有任何其他线索的情况下，这似乎是抓住凯瑟琳凶手的最可能方式。搜查指向了布里斯班内郊的毅力谷，距离威尔斯顿仅几公里。警方在那里的一家寄宿公寓追踪到了弗吉尼亚·休斯顿的一位前男友，名叫肖恩（化名）。当被问及凯瑟琳·马歇尔的谋杀案时，肖恩变得好斗，并拒绝提供DNA样本。鉴于法律没有要求他提供，调查人员暗中跟踪肖恩穿过街道，看看是否有机会出现。当他在人行道上吐痰时，侦探们抓住了机会并迅速行动，获得了唾液样本进行测试。
Whilst awaiting the results, investigators were alerted that Shane had abruptly left his boarding house carrying packed suitcases and gotten into a taxi. Concerned that he was trying to flee, a detective phoned the taxi company, who revealed Shane was on his way to the Brisbane Transit Centre. The detective raced to the centre and spotted Shane waiting for a train to Sydney. He was promptly taken into custody and once at police headquarters, Shane complied with all requests, providing fingerprints and a blood sample. His belongings and clothing were also confiscated for testing. When the results of the DNA tests came back, detectives were once again shocked. Shane wasn't a match to the sample found at the murder scene, nor were any of the other men known to Virginia, Houston or Kathleen Marshall who provided samples. There was a significant man in Kathleen's life that police had yet to find.
在等待结果的同时，调查人员接到警报称，肖恩带着行李箱突然离开了他的寄宿公寓，并上了一辆出租车。担心他试图逃跑，一名侦探给出租车公司打了电话，对方透露肖恩正在前往布里斯班交通中心。侦探赶到中心，发现肖恩正在等火车去悉尼。他立即被拘留，在警察总部，肖恩配合了所有要求，提供了指纹和血样。他的财物和衣物也被没收进行测试。当DNA测试结果出来时，侦探们再次感到震惊。肖恩与谋杀现场发现的样本不匹配，弗吉尼亚·休斯顿或凯瑟琳·马歇尔认识的其他提供样本的男性也不匹配。凯瑟琳的生活中还有一个重要的男人，警方尚未找到。
Kathleen's Daily Planner listed her final vet consultation dated Thursday, February 26. After the 12.30 appointment with Matthew Thompson, Kathleen was scheduled at 1pm to see John Wilson and his unnamed cat. Despite police appeals, efforts to locate John Wilson had so far failed. No one by that name had come forward, leading investigators to assume it was a fake name. Identifying John via his cat seemed an impossible task, until police spoke with Cat Protection Society members, married couple Victor and Pauline Lachardi. Victor and Pauline had paid Kathleen a quick visit shortly before 1pm that Thursday. As they chatted with her out the front of her house, a man approached carrying a white and fawn coloured cat. It was a seal point Siamese breed and the man was holding it against his chest.
凯瑟琳的日常计划表列出了她最后一次兽医咨询，日期为2月26日星期四。在下午12点30分与马修·汤普森预约后，凯瑟琳定于下午1点见约翰·威尔逊和他的猫。尽管警方发出了呼吁，但寻找约翰·威尔逊的努力迄今为止都失败了。没有叫这个名字的人站出来，导致调查人员认为这是一个假名。通过他的猫来识别约翰似乎是一项不可能的任务，直到警方与猫保护协会成员、已婚夫妇维克多和宝琳·拉查迪交谈。维克多和宝琳在那个周四下午1点前不久对凯瑟琳进行了短暂访问。当他们在她家门前与她聊天时，一个男人走过来，抱着一只白色和浅黄色的猫。那是一只海豹重点色暹罗猫，男人把它抱在胸前。
Not wanting to impede on Kathleen's work, Victor and Pauline immediately left. Based on the timing, investigators were certain this man was the John Wilson Kathleen had been expecting. The fact that he was holding the cat in his arms indicated that he was a local, as travelling a long distance with an unrestrained cat would have proven difficult. Detectives had door-knocked the local area on the lookout for owners of seal point Siamese cats, but it wasn't until they saw a photo of one such cat published in the Korea Mail newspaper that their intrigue peaked. The cat was featured alongside an article titled, A Cult Joins Hunt. It described how various clairvoyants were trying to identify Kathleen Marshall's killer through techniques such as automatic writing. One clairvoyant named in the article was Ruth Bennett, a reverend, organist and marriage celebrant for the Spiritualist Church in Windsor.
不想妨碍凯瑟琳的工作，维克多和宝琳立即离开了。根据时间，调查人员确信这个男人就是凯瑟琳一直在等的约翰·威尔逊。他把猫抱在怀里的事实表明他是当地人，因为带着一只不受约束的猫长途旅行会很困难。侦探们在当地挨家挨户寻找海豹重点色暹罗猫的主人，但直到他们看到《信使邮报》上刊登的一张此类猫的照片时，他们的好奇心才达到顶峰。这只猫出现在一篇题为“邪教加入搜捕”的文章旁边。文章描述了各种通灵者如何通过自动书写等技术试图识别凯瑟琳·马歇尔的凶手。文章中提到的其中一位通灵者是露丝·贝内特，她是温莎灵性教会的牧师、管风琴手和婚礼司仪。
She was also a member of the Cat Protection Society. The Spiritualist Church was founded on the belief that spirits of the dead want to communicate with the living. It was a popular place amongst members of the Cat Protection Society, including Virginia Houston, who attended the church regularly to receive spiritual direction. In the Korea Mail article, reverend Ruth Bennett had offered her opinion on Kathleen's murder, saying she'd picked up indications that it was motivated by money or outstanding debts. A photo of Ruth was featured in the story. In it, she was holding one of her pet cats, a seal point Siamese. Although it was the breed of cat detectives had been searching for, Ruth could not have been John Wilson. Still, the investigative spotlight was now on the Spiritualist Church.
她也是猫保护协会的成员。灵性教会建立在死者灵魂想要与生者交流的信念之上。它是猫保护协会成员中的热门场所，包括弗吉尼亚·休斯顿，她经常去教堂接受精神指导。在《信使邮报》的文章中，露丝·贝内特牧师对凯瑟琳的谋杀案发表了看法，称她感觉到这是出于金钱或未偿债务的动机。露丝的照片出现在报道中。照片中，她抱着她的一只宠物猫，一只海豹重点色暹罗猫。虽然这是侦探们一直在寻找的猫品种，但露丝不可能是约翰·威尔逊。尽管如此，调查的聚光灯现在集中在灵性教会身上。
Investigators collected DNA samples from men who worked with or were known to the institution. During one such visit, a detective bumped into a frail-looking, bespectacled man who walked with a hunch. He introduced himself as 49-year-old Andrew Fitzherbert, a professional palm reader who carried out readings at the church. Most significantly, he was the de facto partner of reverend Ruth Bennett. According to all accounts, Andrew was a mild-mannered pacifist, though slightly odd and eccentric. He had many friends and no history of violence or prior convictions. The detective told Andrew why he was there and asked if he'd be willing to provide a blood sample. When told it was voluntary, Andrew abruptly refused.
调查人员从与该机构一起工作或认识的男性那里收集了DNA样本。在一次访问中，一名侦探撞见了一个看起来虚弱、戴着眼镜、驼背的男人。他自我介绍说是49岁的安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特，一名在教堂进行解读的专业手相师。最重要的是，他是露丝·贝内特牧师的事实伴侣。据所有描述，安德鲁是一个温和的和平主义者，尽管有点古怪和离奇。他有很多朋友，没有暴力史或前科。侦探告诉安德鲁他为什么来这里，并询问他是否愿意提供血样。当被告知这是自愿的时，安德鲁断然拒绝了。
As the only witnesses that had crossed paths with the mysterious John Wilson, Victor and Pauline Lachati were handed a photo lineup that featured nine men. The couple immediately recognized photo number nine as the man who had visited Kathleen's house with a seal point Siamese cat before her murder. They'd gotten a good glimpse of him when they drove out of Kathleen's driveway as they had to wait for him to move out of the way. The photo the couple pointed out was that of Andrew Fitzherbert. Narrowing their sights on Andrew, investigators learned that he and Ruth Bennett had met in 1990 at the Theosophical Society, an organization that promotes the idea that a deeper spiritual reality can be established through techniques such as meditation. Andrew dedicated his time to advancing his spiritual awareness and had learned to detach himself from material possessions, only earning what he needed to live comfortably. Through their shared spiritual beliefs, Andrew and Ruth grew close.
作为与神秘的约翰·威尔逊擦肩而过的唯一目击者，维克多和宝琳·拉查迪拿到了一份包含九名男性的照片阵容。这对夫妇立即认出九号照片就是谋杀前带着海豹重点色暹罗猫访问凯瑟琳家的男人。当他们开车离开凯瑟琳的车道时，他们清楚地看到了他，因为他们不得不等他让路。这对夫妇指出的照片是安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的。调查人员将目光锁定在安德鲁身上，了解到他和露丝·贝内特于1990年在通神学会相识，这是一个提倡通过冥想等技术建立更深层精神现实的组织。安德鲁致力于提升自己的精神意识，并学会了摆脱物质占有，只赚取舒适生活所需的钱。通过共同的精神信仰，安德鲁和露丝变得亲密起来。
They ran a tea shop together that also offered tarot readings. It was there the pair met Virginia Houston, who became a regular customer and frequented the shop almost weekly. In 1995, Andrew and Ruth began working at the Spiritualist Church in Windsor and the following year, Virginia urged them to join the Cat Protection Society of Queensland. Ruth's application was processed after the six-month waiting period. For reasons unknown, Andrews was not. Detectives visited Andrew Fitzherbert at his home and noted his physically weak demeanour suited the shallow stab wounds that were inflicted on Kathleen Marshall. When Andrew refused to accompany detectives to the station for an interview, they were forced to place him under arrest. In custody, Andrew said he'd never even met Kathleen Marshall and had no idea where she lived. He only knew who she was because Virginia Houston complained about her constantly. In lieu of a clear motive, investigators wondered if Andrew's rejection from the Cat Protection Society had prompted him to violently confront Kathleen.
他们一起经营一家茶店，也提供塔罗牌解读。正是在那里，两人遇到了弗吉尼亚·休斯顿，她成了常客，几乎每周都光顾这家店。1995年，安德鲁和露丝开始在温莎的灵性教会工作，第二年，弗吉尼亚敦促他们加入昆士兰猫保护协会。露丝的申请在六个月的等待期后得到了处理。由于未知原因，安德鲁的申请没有。侦探们拜访了安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特，注意到他身体虚弱的举止与凯瑟琳·马歇尔身上造成的浅表刀伤相符。当安德鲁拒绝陪同侦探去警局接受采访时，他们被迫将他逮捕。在拘留期间，安德鲁说他甚至从未见过凯瑟琳·马歇尔，也不知道她住在哪里。他只知道她是谁，因为弗吉尼亚·休斯顿不断地抱怨她。在缺乏明确动机的情况下，调查人员怀疑安德鲁被猫保护协会拒绝是否促使他暴力对抗凯瑟琳。
He vehemently denied this allegation, deeming it ridiculous, and those who knew both Kathleen and Andrew weren't aware that the pair had ever met. Andrew explained he wasn't John Wilson because he was doing palm readings from his office in Brisbane at the time John arrived for his 1pm appointment at Kathleen's clinic. Andrew's schedule for Thursday, February 26, which was filled out by his partner Ruth, featured the name Rose and a front at 1pm for an hour each. When asked to provide their contact details, Andrew couldn't. He claimed to only keep limited details about his clients because he didn't want to know any of their personal information prior to giving them a reading. Andrew and Ruth were provided a partial alibi by Ruth's ex-husband, who visited their home on the afternoon of Thursday, February 26. He remained there until 11pm when he said Andrew and Ruth went to bed. Kathleen could have been confronted as late as 3am, but Ruth maintained that Andrew was asleep the entire time. She questioned that if Kathleen had led Andrew into the clinic in the middle of the night, why was she found murdered in a blue and white sundress and not her pyjamas?
他极力否认这一指控，认为这很荒谬，而且那些既认识凯瑟琳又认识安德鲁的人都不知道他们两人曾经见过面。安德鲁解释说他不是约翰·威尔逊，因为在约翰于下午1点到达凯瑟琳诊所赴约时，他正在布里斯班的办公室里进行手相占卜。安德鲁2月26日星期四的日程表是由他的伴侣露丝填写的，上面写着“罗斯”和“前台”，每项各占一小时。当被要求提供客户联系方式时，安德鲁无法提供。他声称只保留有限的客户信息，因为他不想在给他们算命之前知道他们的任何个人信息。安德鲁和露丝得到了露丝前夫的部分不在场证明，他在2月26日星期四下午拜访了他们的家。他一直待到晚上11点，当时他说安德鲁和露丝上床睡觉了。凯瑟琳可能在凌晨3点才遭到袭击，但露丝坚称安德鲁一直都在睡觉。她质疑，如果凯瑟琳在半夜把安德鲁带进诊所，为什么她被发现遇害时穿着一件蓝白相间的夏日连衣裙，而不是睡衣？
Although he continued to profess his innocence, Andrew still refused to provide a DNA sample. In the six hours he was held by police, he avoided going to the bathroom or drinking any water. Detectives applied for a court order that would allow them to forcibly obtain Andrew's blood, but their request was denied on the basis that there was insufficient evidence against him. However, they were granted a warrant to search his home. Three months had passed since Kathleen Marshall's murder when detectives approached Andrew Fitzherbert's residence with a search warrant in hand. They appealed to him one last time, calling him a reasonable man and insisting that all his troubles could be solved in a matter of seconds if he just gave them a blood sample. Andrew remained defiant. He was then asked if he had ever spoken with Kathleen Marshall on the telephone. Andrew answered no. The detective made a surprise revelation.
尽管他继续声称自己无罪，但安德鲁仍然拒绝提供DNA样本。在被警方拘留的六个小时里，他避免上厕所或喝任何水。侦探们申请了法院命令，允许他们强制获取安德鲁的血液，但他们的请求被驳回，理由是针对他的证据不足。然而，他们获得了搜查他家的搜查令。凯瑟琳·马歇尔遇害三个月后，侦探们拿着搜查令来到安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的住所。他们最后一次向他呼吁，称他是一个讲道理的人，并坚持说如果他只是提供一份血液样本，他所有的麻烦都可以在几秒钟内解决。安德鲁仍然不为所动。随后，他被问及是否曾与凯瑟琳·马歇尔通过电话。安德鲁回答没有。侦探随后透露了一个令人惊讶的消息。
Phone records had shown that a 64 second call placed to Kathleen's house on the Tuesday before she was killed had originated from Andrew's residence. The following day, four calls had been made to Kathleen's house from the spiritualist church at a time when Andrew was the only person present. Detectives believed Andrew had made these calls to stage a veterinary appointment with Kathleen using the fake name John Wilson. Although Kathleen only offered her veterinary services to friends and acquaintances, her phone number was readily available as she listed it in the courier mail newspaper each week when advertising her lapicua social dinner group. Andrew Fitzherbert turned pale and started to tremble, but he maintained that he'd never called Kathleen. He then changed his mind, conceding that he had called her to check on his application to the Cat Protection Society. Detectives carried out their search warrant specifically on the lookout for anything that could be used to obtain Andrew Fitzherbert's DNA. They confiscated his toothbrush, hairbrush, pillowcase, coffee mug and a handkerchief, all the while being screamed at by a visibly angry Ruth Bennett.
电话记录显示，在凯瑟琳遇害前的周二，打往她家的一通64秒的电话源自安德鲁的住所。第二天，在安德鲁是唯一在场的人时，从灵学会打出了四通电话到凯瑟琳家。侦探们认为安德鲁打这些电话是为了用假名“约翰·威尔逊”与凯瑟琳预约兽医服务。虽然凯瑟琳只向朋友和熟人提供兽医服务，但她的电话号码很容易获得，因为她每周在《信使邮报》上为她的拉皮库阿社交晚宴小组做广告时都会列出该号码。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特脸色苍白，开始颤抖，但他坚持说他从未给凯瑟琳打过电话。随后他改变了主意，承认他确实给她打过电话，是为了查询他向猫咪保护协会提交的申请。侦探们执行了搜查令，专门寻找任何可以用来获取安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特DNA的东西。他们没收了他的牙刷、发刷、枕套、咖啡杯和手帕，在此过程中，露丝·贝内特一直愤怒地尖叫。
Testing of Andrew's DNA samples were fast tracked, allowing the results to come back the next day. Samples taken from his handkerchief and one of his socks were compared with the profile of the male DNA found inside Kathleen's clinic. It was a match. Andrew Fitzherbert was placed under arrest and investigators were finally allowed to obtain a sample of his blood. It reinforced previous findings that it was his DNA in Kathleen's clinic. Investigators concluded that Andrew had likely injured himself during the attack, causing his blood to drop throughout the scene. He attempted to clean it up afterwards, but during this process, a few droplets of water down blood had splashed out from the sink and onto a nearby plastic bag. He then bled onto the cardboard box used to prop himself up and out of the window.
安德鲁的DNA样本检测被快速处理，结果在第二天就出来了。从他的手帕和一只袜子上提取的样本与在凯瑟琳诊所内发现的男性DNA图谱进行了比对。结果吻合。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特被捕，调查人员终于获准获取了他的血液样本。这加强了之前的发现，即凯瑟琳诊所里的DNA确实是他的。调查人员得出结论，安德鲁在袭击过程中可能受了伤，导致他的血滴落在整个现场。他事后试图清理，但在清理过程中，几滴带血的水从水槽溅到了附近的塑料袋上。随后，他流血滴在了用来支撑他爬出窗户的纸板箱上。
While police ran with this theory, Andrew refused to offer any explanation as to how his blood wound up in Kathleen's clinic. He stood by his story that he had never been there nor ever met her. He kept quiet and appeared unemotional as he was formally charged with Kathleen's murder. His partner Ruth Bennett also chose to remain silent. Andrew pleaded not guilty and faced the Brisbane Supreme Court in July 1999. In the absence of any witnesses, murder weapon or clear motive, the presence of Andrew Fitzherbert's DNA at the scene of the crime was fundamental to the prosecution's case. They argued that the DNA alone was enough to implicate him as the killer. As such, they didn't feel the need to address the Cat Protection Society and its internal conflicts or the mysterious circumstances surrounding John Wilson.
当警方根据这一理论进行调查时，安德鲁拒绝就他的血是如何出现在凯瑟琳诊所的做出任何解释。他坚持自己的说法，即他从未去过那里，也从未见过她。在被正式指控谋杀凯瑟琳时，他保持沉默，表现得毫无情绪。他的伴侣露丝·贝内特也选择保持沉默。安德鲁拒不认罪，并于1999年7月在布里斯班最高法院受审。在没有目击者、凶器或明确动机的情况下，安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的DNA出现在犯罪现场是检方案件的基础。他们辩称，仅凭DNA就足以证明他是凶手。因此，他们觉得没有必要去处理猫咪保护协会及其内部冲突，或者关于“约翰·威尔逊”的神秘情况。
Of primary importance was the sample of Andrew's blood found on the plastic bag by the sink. It was the only sample that also contained Kathleen's blood. This combination could have only occurred if both were injured at the same time, ruling out the possibility that Andrew had bled there on another occasion. The prosecution asserted that the chances of the DNA at the crime scene matching someone other than Andrew Fitzherbert was one in 1400 million. The defense highlighted the lack of motive as a major flaw in the prosecution's case. He also pointed out that the excessive amount of blood at the crime scene meant the killer would have been soaked red, which would have surely attracted attention. The possibility that Andrew had fled in his car to avoid witnesses couldn't be proven as it was never forensically examined.
最重要的是在水槽旁的塑料袋上发现的安德鲁的血样。这是唯一一个同时也含有凯瑟琳血液的样本。这种组合只有在两人同时受伤的情况下才会发生，排除了安德鲁在其他时间在那里流血的可能性。检方断言，犯罪现场的DNA与安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特以外的人相符的几率为14亿分之一。辩方强调缺乏动机是检方案件的一个重大缺陷。他还指出，犯罪现场过量的血液意味着凶手会被染成红色，这肯定会引起注意。安德鲁是否开车逃离以避开目击者这一可能性无法得到证实，因为他的车从未经过法医检查。
In his testimony, Andrew said he'd never attacked anybody in his entire life and was not responsible for Kathleen's murder. He maintained he had no explanation for how his blood came to be in Kathleen's veterinary clinic. The prosecution emphasised that this mystery only seemed to implicate him further. They argued it would have been a smarter move if Andrew had just admitted to being in the clinic and had come up with an explanation from there, instead of avoiding the indisputable evidence. It took the jury four and a half hours to reach a verdict. For the murder of Kathleen Marshall, Andrew Fitzherbert was found guilty. It was the first time in Australia and only the third in the world that someone had been convicted of a crime based solely on DNA evidence. Andrew was visibly devastated.
在证词中，安德鲁说他一生中从未攻击过任何人，对凯瑟琳的谋杀案不负责任。他坚持说，对于他的血是如何出现在凯瑟琳的兽医诊所的，他没有任何解释。检方强调，这个谜团似乎只会让他更加难以脱身。他们辩称，如果安德鲁只是承认去过诊所并从那里编造一个解释，而不是回避无可辩驳的证据，那会是更明智的做法。陪审团花了四个半小时才达成裁决。因谋杀凯瑟琳·马歇尔，安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特被判有罪。这是澳大利亚历史上第一次、也是世界上第三次仅凭DNA证据就将某人定罪。安德鲁显然深受打击。
A victim impact statement from Kathleen's siblings was presented to the court. It read, in part, Kathleen was estranged from us for some years. After the death of our parents, we went our separate ways. However, we never wished her any harm or unhappiness. In fact, we prayed that she would in fact achieve a very happy and harmonious life. Although Kathleen seemed to have been a difficult woman, she had also championed great causes. And like any person, she deserved to have lived a full and rich life free from criminal violence.
凯瑟琳的兄弟姐妹向法庭提交了一份受害者影响陈述。其中部分内容写道：凯瑟琳与我们疏远多年。父母去世后，我们各奔东西。然而，我们从未希望她受到任何伤害或不幸。事实上，我们祈祷她能过上非常幸福和谐的生活。虽然凯瑟琳似乎是一个难以相处的人，但她也支持过伟大的事业。像任何人一样，她理应过上充实而丰富的生活，远离犯罪暴力。
Her murder was savage and brutal, and the person responsible deserved a hefty punishment. During sentencing, the judge told Andrew Fitzherbert, This is a crime of which you would not have been convicted, but for the recent explosion in knowledge in the field of genetics. He added that the motive would remain unknown unless Andrew chose to reveal it. Throughout the trial, Andrew had shown no remorse, and he would, quote, Now suffer the consequences of a conviction, if not your conscience, for what you have done. Andrew Fitzherbert was sentenced to life imprisonment, which in Queensland carried a minimum term of 15 years. Kathleen's friends and fellow members of the Cat Protection Society spoke of their relief that justice had been served,
她的谋杀案残忍而野蛮，肇事者理应受到严厉的惩罚。在宣判时，法官对安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特说：“这是一起如果没有遗传学领域知识的近期爆炸式增长，你本不会被定罪的犯罪。”他补充说，除非安德鲁选择揭露，否则动机将永远是个谜。在整个审判过程中，安德鲁没有表现出任何悔意，他将“现在承受定罪的后果，如果不是良心上的谴责，也是为你所做的一切承担后果”。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特被判处终身监禁，在昆士兰州，这意味着至少15年的刑期。凯瑟琳的朋友和猫咪保护协会的成员们表示，他们对正义得到伸张感到宽慰，
but the wider reaction to Andrew's guilty verdict was mixed. Some believed that his blood at the crime scene made it an open and shut case. Others weren't so sure, arguing that DNA evidence alone wasn't enough to convict. One of Andrew's supporters expressed disbelief that his mild-mannered and gentle friend could be ruled a violent killer, saying, It would be laughable if it wasn't so serious. The question was raised as to why Andrew was so reluctant to voluntarily provide a blood sample if he was innocent. Andrew maintained this was simply because he didn't trust the police. According to entomologist Professor Russell Luke, Kathleen Marshall was murdered sometime between Thursday, February 26 at 9pm and 3am Friday, February 27.
但公众对安德鲁有罪判决的反应不一。一些人认为，他在犯罪现场的血迹使这成为一个显而易见的案件。另一些人则不那么确定，认为仅凭DNA证据不足以定罪。安德鲁的一位支持者表示，无法相信他那温和、善良的朋友会被判定为暴力杀手，并说：“如果不是这么严重，这简直可笑。”有人提出疑问，如果安德鲁是无辜的，为什么他如此不情愿自愿提供血液样本。安德鲁坚持认为，这仅仅是因为他不信任警察。据昆虫学家拉塞尔·卢克教授称，凯瑟琳·马歇尔是在2月26日星期四晚上9点到2月27日星期五凌晨3点之间的某个时间被谋杀的。
Professor Luke later adjusted this time frame, after six independent witnesses claimed to have seen Kathleen 11 separate times, going about her business in Wilston throughout Friday, wearing the blue and white striped sundress she was later killed in. None of these witnesses knew Andrew Fitzherbert. Professor Luke accepted the decomposition of Kathleen's remains and the developments of maggots found in her wounds could have been affected if the temperature inside her clinic was higher than he had originally estimated, even by a single degree. It could have also been impacted by the light in the surgery, as, quote, flies don't normally over-posit in the dark. Therefore, he ultimately concluded that she could have been attacked sometime on Friday, but by 3pm at the absolute latest. However, there was something that didn't fit this timeline.
卢克教授后来调整了这一时间框架，此前有六名独立证人声称在周五全天看到凯瑟琳在威尔斯顿忙碌了11次，穿着她后来遇害时所穿的那件蓝白条纹夏日连衣裙。这些证人中没有一个人认识安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特。卢克教授承认，如果她诊所内的温度比他最初估计的高，哪怕只高一度，凯瑟琳遗体的腐烂程度和伤口中蛆虫的发育都可能受到影响。这也可能受到手术室光线的影响，因为“苍蝇通常不会在黑暗中过度产卵”。因此，他最终得出结论，她可能是在周五的某个时间遭到袭击，但最晚不超过下午3点。然而，有些事情与这个时间表不符。
Warren Smith knew Kathleen Marshall very well. The pair had lived across the street from one another for two decades, and Warren had become so accustomed to Kathleen's presence that he recognized her car by the pup putt sound it emitted. He could even tell when someone entered or exited her front door by the distinctive noise of its knocker. At 4.45 on the Friday afternoon, Warren heard Kathleen's Toyota station wagon approaching as he collected his bins and mail out the front of his house. He turned towards it, noticing Kathleen as she drove towards her home. Just over an hour later, at around 6pm, Warren heard Kathleen's front door slam shut. At this time, several other neighbors were standing out in the street chatting to one another. All of a sudden, two screams pierced the quiet night air.
沃伦·史密斯非常了解凯瑟琳·马歇尔。两人在街对面住了二十年，沃伦已经习惯了凯瑟琳的存在，以至于他能通过她车发出的“噗噗”声认出她的车。他甚至能通过她前门敲门声的独特声音分辨出有人进出。周五下午4点45分，沃伦在自家门前收集垃圾和邮件时，听到了凯瑟琳的丰田旅行车驶近的声音。他转向那边，注意到凯瑟琳开车朝家驶去。一个多小时后，大约下午6点，沃伦听到凯瑟琳的前门砰地关上。当时，其他几位邻居正站在街上聊天。突然，两声尖叫划破了安静的夜空。
It sounded as though they came from the direction of Kathleen's house, but nobody followed up on the noise. Then at 8pm, Warren Smith heard Kathleen's front door close again. By this stage, Kathleen had failed to show up to the dinner planned for her Lepicua social group in the city. Two days later, she was found murdered. Criminologist and forensic psychologist Professor Paul Wilson would later highlight this discrepancy in his book, Five Drops of Blood, Murder in the Cat Protection Society. Andrew Fitzherbert was convicted on the basis that he could have carried out Kathleen's murder in the timeframe presented by Professor Russell Luke. Yet, if witness accounts were to be believed, Kathleen was killed the following night at around 6pm, with her killer possibly staying at her house until 8pm. Andrew Fitzherbert had spent that Friday visiting thrift stores with Ruth.
听起来像是从凯瑟琳家的方向传来的，但没有人去查看噪音。然后晚上8点，沃伦·史密斯再次听到凯瑟琳的前门关上。此时，凯瑟琳没有出现在她计划在城里参加的莱皮库阿社交小组的晚宴上。两天后，她被发现遇害。犯罪学家和法医心理学家保罗·威尔逊教授后来在他的书《五滴血，猫咪保护协会的谋杀案》中强调了这一差异。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特被定罪的依据是他可能在拉塞尔·卢克教授提出的时间框架内实施了对凯瑟琳的谋杀。然而，如果证人的证词可信，凯瑟琳是在第二天晚上6点左右被杀的，凶手可能一直待在她的房子里直到晚上8点。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特那个周五和露丝一起逛了旧货店。
They returned home just after 4pm, as confirmed by Ruth's son, who lived with the couple. He said Andrew didn't leave the house again until 6.45pm. At that time, Andrew and Ruth left to attend a meditation and seance session with five others at the home of a friend. The couple arrived 45 minutes later. This time was consistent with the distance they had to travel. It took 20 minutes to drive from Andrew's home to Kathleen's. Professor Wilson didn't think Andrew was capable of detouring to confront and kill Kathleen, attempt to clean the crime scene and himself, then make it to his meditation group on time. Author Ted Deuce spoke with the woman who hosted the event, to determine if there was anything about Andrew that night that was markedly suspicious.
正如与这对夫妇住在一起的露丝的儿子所证实的那样，他们在下午4点多回到家。他说安德鲁直到晚上6点45分才再次离开家。当时，安德鲁和露丝离开去参加一个朋友家举行的冥想和降神会，还有其他五个人参加。这对夫妇45分钟后到达。这个时间与他们必须行驶的距离是一致的。从安德鲁家开车到凯瑟琳家需要20分钟。威尔逊教授认为安德鲁没有能力绕道去对抗并杀死凯瑟琳，试图清理犯罪现场和自己，然后准时赶到他的冥想小组。作者泰德·杜斯与主持该活动的一位女士交谈，以确定那天晚上安德鲁是否有任何明显可疑的地方。
She said he was his usual calm and cheerful self. Professor Wilson wasn't the only one raising doubts about the science used to implicate Andrew Fitzherbert. Leading DNA expert Professor Barry Botcher was no stranger to wrongful conviction cases. He had provided expert witness testimony that helped exonerate Lindy Chamberlain in the death of her baby daughter Azaria, as covered in episode 136 of Case File. Professor Botcher disagreed with the prosecution's assertions that Andrew Fitzherbert's DNA was a match to the Kathleen Marshall crime scene sample at odds of 1400 million to one. He said this was based on one scientist's interpretation of the data. Other reports claimed the odds were closer to one in 100,000. There is just no possibility of determining the accuracy of the figure given to the jury, but it would have sounded highly impressive to them.
她说他和平常一样冷静、开朗。威尔逊教授并不是唯一一个对用于指控安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的科学提出质疑的人。领先的DNA专家巴里·博彻教授对冤假错案并不陌生。他曾提供专家证词，帮助林迪·张伯伦在她的女婴阿扎里亚死亡案中洗清罪名，正如《案件档案》第136集所报道的那样。博彻教授不同意检方关于安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的DNA与凯瑟琳·马歇尔犯罪现场样本以14亿分之一的几率相符的断言。他说这是基于一位科学家对数据的解读。其他报告称，几率更接近10万分之一。根本无法确定给陪审团的数字的准确性，但这对他们来说听起来非常令人印象深刻。
Upon reviewing the laboratory results from the crime scene, Professor Botcher concluded that the male blood samples had degraded faster than the others taken from Kathleen's clinic. He theorized that it could have been planted there earlier, while also questioning, How you would pick five drops of blood from the amount of blood from a frenzied attack, I don't know. In response, the forensic expert responsible for the original laboratory results said that the possibility of evidence having been planted could only be considered in conjunction with an extreme conspiracy theory. In March 2000, Andrew Fitzherbert lodged an appeal, claiming that the results of DNA testing were falsified in order to convict him. In their ruling, the court of appeal concluded that the blood-based evidence implicating Andrew in Kathleen's murder, while unexplained, was enough to support the conviction. They found no evidence that the recorded results of the DNA testing were fraudulent or faked. As such, the appeal was rejected.
在审查了犯罪现场的实验室结果后，博彻教授得出结论，男性血样比从凯瑟琳诊所提取的其他样本降解得更快。他推测它可能是在更早的时候被放置在那里的，同时也质疑道：“我不知道你是怎么从一场疯狂袭击产生的大量血液中挑选出五滴血的。”作为回应，负责原始实验室结果的法医专家表示，证据被栽赃的可能性只能与极端的阴谋论结合起来考虑。2000年3月，安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特提出上诉，声称DNA检测结果是为了给他定罪而伪造的。在上诉法院的裁决中，法院得出结论，虽然无法解释，但指控安德鲁谋杀凯瑟琳的血液证据足以支持定罪。他们没有发现任何证据表明记录的DNA检测结果是欺诈或伪造的。因此，上诉被驳回。
Four years later in February 2004, Andrew applied to have the crime scene samples retested at another facility in Western Australia. He requested other items such as the shoes found under the clinic's sink also be re-examined. The shoes were originally taken for analysis and dried blood was swabbed from them, but no further testing was ever conducted. They were assumed to have been Kathleen's shoes, but this had never been confirmed. The testing would be funded by a support group who believed in Andrew's innocence. He was backed by The Innocence Project, a non-profit organisation dedicated to exonerating wrongfully convicted individuals through the use of DNA testing. Andrew's request was denied by Queensland's Attorney General on the grounds that Andrew's supporters had failed to, quote, raise any justifiable doubt about the correctness of the sampling or testing of the DNA material.
四年后的2004年2月，安德鲁申请将犯罪现场的样本送到西澳大利亚的另一家机构进行重新检测。他要求对诊所水槽下发现的鞋子等其他物品也进行重新检查。这些鞋子最初被拿去分析，并从上面提取了干血迹，但没有进行进一步的测试。人们认为这是凯瑟琳的鞋子，但这从未得到证实。检测将由一个相信安德鲁无罪的支持小组资助。他得到了“无罪计划”的支持，这是一个致力于通过使用DNA检测为被错误定罪的个人洗清罪名的非营利组织。安德鲁的请求被昆士兰州总检察长驳回，理由是安德鲁的支持者未能“对DNA材料的采样或检测的正确性提出任何合理的怀疑”。
Andrew had also been given the chance to have these samples retested at the trial and his appeal at the government's expense, but failed to do so. He claimed he was not aware of this right. His lawyer said that the Attorney General had missed the point of the application, stating that their issue wasn't with the testing of the material, but the analysis of the results. She also cited the improvements in DNA testing since the trial. Prior to Andrew's trial, major shortcomings were uncovered in the handling of the Kathleen Marshall murder investigation. They included poorly documented records, unsealed evidence, unrestricted access to lab specimens, and potential specimen contamination. In 2002, the centre that handled the case's DNA testing was warned to improve its standards or risk losing its accreditation after issues were raised regarding record control, methodology, handling of exhibits, and reports of results. Then there was the matter of investigative leads that were unexplored, overlooked, or ignored.
安德鲁在审判和上诉时也有机会由政府出资对这些样本进行重新检测，但他没有这样做。他声称他不知道有这项权利。他的律师表示，总检察长没有理解申请的重点，称他们的问题不在于材料的检测，而在于结果的分析。她还提到了自审判以来DNA检测的改进。在安德鲁受审之前，凯瑟琳·马歇尔谋杀案调查的处理过程中发现了重大缺陷。其中包括记录不全、证据未密封、实验室标本不受限制的访问以及潜在的标本污染。2002年，处理该案件DNA检测的中心因记录控制、方法、展品处理和结果报告方面的问题被警告要提高标准，否则将面临失去认证的风险。此外，还有一些未被探索、忽视或忽略的调查线索。
They are detailed in Ted Doe's book, Crucial Errors in Murder Investigations, and include the following. At 2.15pm on Friday, February 27, 1998, Kathleen was seen driving away from her house with a male passenger. Her dogs were also in the car. Kathleen's friends claimed that her dogs only tolerated two males. One was a man who lived with Kathleen for a brief period of time in 1997, whom she was still friendly with. The other was someone who did odd jobs around her place. Upon examination after her murder, Kathleen's car was noted to have been thoroughly claimed. Neither of these two men were explored as significant suspects in Kathleen's murder.
它们在泰德·杜斯的书《谋杀调查中的关键错误》中有详细记载，包括以下内容。1998年2月27日星期五下午2点15分，有人看到凯瑟琳带着一名男性乘客开车离开她的房子。她的狗也在车里。凯瑟琳的朋友声称，她的狗只容忍两名男性。一个是1997年与凯瑟琳住过一段时间的男人，她与他仍然很友好。另一个是经常在她家做零工的人。在谋杀案发生后的检查中，凯瑟琳的车被发现被彻底清理过。这两个人都没有被作为凯瑟琳谋杀案的重要嫌疑人进行调查。
Additionally, two cars were seen parked outside of Kathleen's home late on Friday. One was a resprayed dark brown 1976 Ford Falcon station wagon spotted at 4.10pm. The other was a small blue car sighted at 6pm. Multiple witnesses saw these vehicles, but they were never questioned by police. Cars matching these descriptions were owned by other members of the Cat Protection Society, specifically those who later discovered Kathleen's body. They denied having any communication with Kathleen that weekend whatsoever. Ted Doos wrote in his book, quote, Why has an Andrew Fitzherbert been set free? The answer is simple.
此外，周五深夜有人看到两辆车停在凯瑟琳家外面。一辆是下午4点10分发现的重新喷漆的深棕色1976年福特猎鹰旅行车。另一辆是下午6点看到的一辆蓝色小车。多名目击者看到了这些车辆，但他们从未受到警察的询问。符合这些描述的汽车属于猫咪保护协会的其他成员，特别是那些后来发现凯瑟琳尸体的人。他们否认那个周末与凯瑟琳有任何交流。泰德·杜斯在他的书中写道：“为什么安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特没有被释放？答案很简单。”
Fitzherbert's DNA was found at the murder scene, and he can't explain how it got there. Regarded as an exemplary prisoner in 2014 at the age of 65, Andrew Fitzherbert was released on parole after serving 16 years for Kathleen Marshall's murder. In an attempt to get his life back on track, he resumed his regular activities, including palm reading. Andrew said he had no anger about the past, but was still interested in clearing his name. Current parole conditions forbid him from discussing his case with the media. The only other person who was publicly suspected of killing Kathleen had subsequently vilified by the media was her arch nemesis, Virginia Houston. Andrew's conviction had essentially vindicated Virginia, but his assertions of innocence prevented complete closure. Acknowledging it would take her years to recover from the traumatic experience, Virginia stated,
菲茨赫伯特的DNA在谋杀现场被发现，他无法解释它是如何出现在那里的。2014年，65岁的安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特被视为模范囚犯，在因谋杀凯瑟琳·马歇尔服刑16年后获准假释。为了让生活重回正轨，他恢复了日常活动，包括手相占卜。安德鲁说他对过去没有愤怒，但仍然有兴趣洗清自己的名字。目前的假释条件禁止他与媒体讨论他的案件。唯一一个被公开怀疑杀害凯瑟琳并随后被媒体诋毁的人是她的死对头弗吉尼亚·休斯顿。安德鲁的定罪基本上证明了弗吉尼亚的清白，但他对无罪的断言阻止了彻底的了结。弗吉尼亚承认她需要多年时间才能从创伤经历中恢复过来，她表示：
Truth is the daughter of time, and I think the truth will emerge with time. Andrew Fitzherbert has caused enormous trouble and trauma to dozens and dozens of innocent people, and I have not a flack of sympathy. There is one alternative theory that could exonerate both Andrew and Virginia. According to author Ted Doos, there was one possibility that hadn't been explored by investigators. Doos cited an earlier case in Quebec where a cat owner lost a pint of blood after being attacked by their pet. Doos pointed out that Kathleen's cushing disease caused her skin to become fragile and tear easily. He theorized that after attacking Kathleen, a cat could have jumped out of the broken window, left a blood on the foliage outside, and wandered off into the night, explaining why no footprints had been found at the crime scene and why there was an empty cat cage on the floor.
“真理是时间的女儿，我认为真理会随着时间显现。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特给几十个无辜的人带来了巨大的麻烦和创伤，我对他一点同情都没有。”有一种替代理论可以使安德鲁和弗吉尼亚都免受指控。据作者泰德·杜斯称，有一种可能性没有被调查人员探索过。杜斯引用了魁北克省早些时候发生的一起案件，一名猫主人在被宠物袭击后失血一品脱。杜斯指出，凯瑟琳的库欣氏病导致她的皮肤变得脆弱，容易撕裂。他推测，在袭击凯瑟琳后，一只猫可能从破碎的窗户跳了出去，在户外的叶子上留下了血迹，然后游荡到夜色中，这解释了为什么犯罪现场没有发现脚印，以及为什么地板上有一个空的猫笼。
This theory was refuted by the experienced pathologist who conducted Kathleen's autopsy. He determined that Kathleen's wounds were caused by a sharp instrument as a cat's claws or teeth would have produced wounds with jagged edges. In October 2000, the Cat Protection Society of Queensland went into voluntary liquidation. They had been plagued by further infighting, missing funds, and the irreparable damage done during the trial of Andrew Fitzherbert. Disgruntled members sought a probe into the society's financial affairs, claiming that $90,000 had disappeared in an 18-month period. Virginia Houston opposed the liquidation, claiming that the organization still had a role to play in cat welfare. Eventually, on February 7, 2017, the Cat Protection Society of Queensland was deregistered by a Supreme Court order. Catherine Stephenson
这一理论被进行凯瑟琳尸检的经验丰富的病理学家驳回。他确定凯瑟琳的伤口是由锐器造成的，因为猫的爪子或牙齿会产生边缘参差不齐的伤口。2000年10月，昆士兰猫咪保护协会进入自愿清算程序。他们一直受到进一步内斗、资金缺失以及安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特审判期间造成的不可挽回的损害的困扰。不满的成员寻求对该协会的财务状况进行调查，声称在18个月内有9万美元不翼而飞。弗吉尼亚·休斯顿反对清算，声称该组织在猫福利方面仍有作用。最终，2017年2月7日，昆士兰猫咪保护协会被最高法院命令注销。凯瑟琳·斯蒂芬森
Catherine Stephenson was on her way to work on the morning of Friday, February 27, 1998, when she spotted her old school friend, Kathleen Marshall. She recognized Kathleen easily as she hadn't changed much since they went to school together 30 years prior. Catherine wrote about the chance siding in her personal diary, unaware that within hours, Kathleen would be dead. As one of the six witnesses to see Kathleen in the hours before then, Catherine's recollections played a significant part in extending the time frame of the attack. It was around 10.15am when she observed Kathleen's Toyota station wagon pull up to a stop behind her own car at the Wilston shops. While they didn't interact, Catherine watched Kathleen as she headed into the nearby news agency, dressed in her blue and white striped sundress. Kathleen then affixed a poster to the front window of the shop. It featured the details of a missing pregnant cat.
1998年2月27日星期五早上，凯瑟琳·斯蒂芬森在上班路上看到了她的老同学凯瑟琳·马歇尔。她很容易就认出了凯瑟琳，因为她自30年前一起上学以来并没有太大变化。凯瑟琳在她的个人日记中写下了这次偶然的相遇，不知道几个小时后凯瑟琳就会死去。作为在那个时间点之前看到凯瑟琳的六名证人之一，凯瑟琳的回忆在延长袭击时间框架方面发挥了重要作用。大约上午10点15分，她观察到凯瑟琳的丰田旅行车在威尔斯顿商店停在她自己的车后面。虽然她们没有互动，但凯瑟琳看着凯瑟琳走向附近的报刊代理处，穿着她那件蓝白条纹的夏日连衣裙。凯瑟琳随后在商店的前窗贴了一张海报。上面有关于一只失踪怀孕猫的详细信息。
Phone records would later reveal that on the following day of Saturday, February 28, Reverend Ruth Bennett had placed a call to Animal Welfare Organization, the RSPCA, to report that her pet cat had gone missing. It was a pregnant seal point Siamese named Zilla. Andrew Fitzherbert claimed that Zilla had vanished from home two days earlier, on Thursday the 26th. He said he had spent some time in the garden calling her name, but his search effort didn't extend beyond that. The day Zilla went missing was the day that John Wilson, later identified as Andrew Fitzherbert, visited Kathleen Marshall's clinic. He was seen carrying an unrestrained seal point Siamese cat. Was it possible that Zilla had run away while under Kathleen's care, and a devastated Andrew then returned to confront her in retaliation? Although a missing cat seemed like an extreme motive for murder, it wasn't out of the realm of speculation.
电话记录后来显示，在第二天2月28日星期六，露丝·贝内特牧师曾给动物福利组织RSPCA打过电话，报告她的宠物猫失踪了。那是一只怀孕的海豹重点色暹罗猫，名叫齐拉。安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特声称齐拉两天前，即26日星期四就从家里消失了。他说他在花园里花了一些时间叫她的名字，但他的搜寻工作仅限于此。齐拉失踪的那天，正是后来被确认为安德鲁·菲茨赫伯特的“约翰·威尔逊”访问凯瑟琳·马歇尔诊所的日子。有人看到他带着一只未受约束的海豹重点色暹罗猫。齐拉是否有可能在凯瑟琳的照看下跑掉了，而心烦意乱的安德鲁随后回来进行报复？虽然失踪的猫似乎是一个极端的谋杀动机，但这并非不可能推测。
As her final act of charity, Kathleen Marshall bequeathed $100,000 to the University of Queensland School of Veterinary Science, the same facility she herself had graduated from with honors in 1968. Aided by the funds from Kathleen's estate, the University unveiled a new conference and meeting venue named the Kathleen Lamborn Building, which was Kathleen's maiden name. The modern brick structure sits in a leafy and quiet part of the campus. It is a meeting place for students studying their veterinary degree, as Kathleen Marshall did before them. 250 mourners had attended Kathleen's funeral to pay their respects. Even though she could be a difficult woman, her acquaintances still admired her. She was, after all, a passionate campaigner and powerful advocate for animal welfare. During her funeral service, music by her favorite classical composers, Johann Bach and Frederic Chopin were played on string quartet and piano.
作为她最后的慈善行为，凯瑟琳·马歇尔向昆士兰大学兽医科学学院遗赠了10万美元，这正是她自己于1968年以优异成绩毕业的机构。在凯瑟琳遗产资金的帮助下，大学揭幕了一个新的会议和聚会场所，命名为“凯瑟琳·兰伯恩大楼”，这是凯瑟琳的娘家姓。这座现代化的砖结构建筑坐落在校园里一个绿树成荫、安静的地方。它是像凯瑟琳·马歇尔之前一样学习兽医专业的学生的聚会场所。250名哀悼者参加了凯瑟琳的葬礼以表示敬意。尽管她可能是一个难以相处的人，但她的熟人仍然钦佩她。毕竟，她是一位充满激情的活动家和动物福利的有力倡导者。在她的葬礼期间，她最喜欢的古典作曲家约翰·巴赫和弗雷德里克·肖邦的音乐由弦乐四重奏和钢琴演奏。
Aside from her love of animals, Kathleen also had a love of classical music. Until her death, she studied piano at the Queensland Conservatorium. There, she used her friendships with prominent musicians to organize fundraising concerts for promising young musicians to study overseas. As a young woman, Kathleen lived briefly in London. It was there that she purchased one of her most beloved possessions, an antique Beckstein piano. Unable to part with it, Kathleen had it shipped back to Australia when she returned home, where it took pride of place in her lounge room. It was never determined whether the songbook on its stand that was turned to Chopin's The Funeral March was a clue left by her killer, or just a morbid coincidence. It was there that she purchased one of her most beloved possessions, an antique Beckstein piano.
除了对动物的热爱，凯瑟琳还热爱古典音乐。直到去世前，她一直在昆士兰音乐学院学习钢琴。在那里，她利用与著名音乐家的友谊，组织筹款音乐会，帮助有前途的年轻音乐家出国留学。年轻时，凯瑟琳曾在伦敦短暂居住。正是在那里，她购买了她最珍贵的财产之一，一架古董贝希斯坦钢琴。无法割舍，凯瑟琳在回国时把它运回了澳大利亚，它在她的客厅里占据了显眼的位置。从未确定架子上翻到肖邦《葬礼进行曲》的乐谱是凶手留下的线索，还是仅仅是一个病态的巧合。正是在那里，她购买了她最珍贵的财产之一，一架古董贝希斯坦钢琴。
It was there that she purchased one of her most beloved possessions, an antique Beckstein piano. It was there that she purchased one of her most beloved possessions, an antique Beckstein piano. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
正是在那里，她购买了她最珍贵的财产之一，一架古董贝希斯坦钢琴。正是在那里，她购买了她最珍贵的财产之一，一架古董贝希斯坦钢琴。你。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。